president trump travels to a gulf coast
today that is reeling from hurricane
lore to get a firsthand look at the
damage and recovery efforts
in texas and louisiana the visits come
after his acceptance speech of the
republican nomination on the white house
lawn and his quick return of the
campaign trail
the president's actions and recent often
unmasked activity is apparently taking a
toll
on those charged with keeping him safe
paula reed has that story from the white
house this morning paul good morning
good morning jeff we'll fresh off his
acceptance speech for the republican
nomination president trump was back on
the campaign trail addressing a crowd in
new hampshire
a state he nearly lost in 2016 but is
hoping to pick up
this time he made an impassioned pitch
for why he deserves a second term
and escalated his attacks on his
opponent
i got to win new hampshire and i love
the people president trump greeted a
crowd of over 1400
as he arrived in new hampshire he kicked
off the event by praising his convention
speech
was that just compelling and incredible
television but really that was an
exciting
a really good quality convention
and blasted the protesters who gathered
outside the white house thursday to
disrupt his address
the thugs outside because the democratic
mayor
of washington d.c
it's another democrat that's not
believing
in law and order
but he made no mention of the 57th
anniversary of the march on washington
which was commemorated friday amid
national fallout over police shootings
joe biden marked the occasion by
tweeting it's up to all of us to carry
on the march toward equality
liberty and justice for all
the white house was widely criticized
for a lack of masks or
social distancing at the rnc as nearly a
thousand americans still die each day
from covid
but in new hampshire where face
coverings are required
red trump masks dotted the crowd the
washington post reported friday that
dozens of secret service agents have
been sickened or sidelined
after coming into contact with those who
have covet amid the president's frequent
travels during the pandemic
in a statement the white house insisted
that all travel plans
incorporate current cdc guidance and
best practices for limiting covid19
exposure to the greatest extent possible
as the campaign continues to heat up
america's top
general the chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff mark milley wrote a letter to
congress
saying that the u.s military will not
get involved in the november election
even if the results are disputed or the
election is contested
instead he says they will defer to the
courts and in this letter he says he
truly believes in the importance
of an apolitical military dana
all right paula thank you